alright let's talk about the two things
that can help you dissolve gall stones
now anything that I say is not meant to
replace medical care check with your
doctor before implementing this advice
and also there's a limitation of matter
if your gall bladder is completely
filled with stones it's gonna be
unlikely that you're gonna be able to
dissolve all those stones so I'm talking
about let's say you have one or two
stones you may want to try this first
first thing you need to know is that
will causes gall stones it's not a high
level of cholesterol that causes stones
it's a super concentrated amount of
cholesterol with a lack of bile salts
okay so if you have enough bile salts
then that is going to help keep the
cholesterol from saturating and forming
this crystal the two things are number
one omega-3 fatty acids
it's a polyunsaturated fatty acid I'm
talking about fish oils fish oil has the
ability to decrease bilberry of
saturation of your cholesterol
it's the cholesterol that's going
through the bile ducts in the liver and
this can decrease the risk of gall
stones now I would recommend instead of
fish oil specifically cod liver oil
why because cod liver oil has the same
omega-3 fatty acids in fish oil but it
has two extra benefits one is it has
vitamin A and number two it has vitamin
D vitamin D itself can reduce the
gallbladder sludge the stasis that
accumulates in the gall bladder
so cod liver oil would be a much better
option than just fish oil so that's
number one and number two purify bile
salts bile salts are something that your
body makes and you can also get them in
a supplement and they can dissolve
stones and decrease the crystal
formation there you have it the two
remedies but there's three things you
need to know
insulin cortisol and estrogen and high
amounts can increase your risk of
getting gall stones so number one you
want to cut down your carbs number two
you want to cut down your stress
number three you want to handle any type
of estrogen dominant situation if you
want more information about that I put a
link down below alright thanks for
watching with another amazing recipe no
brains
no sugar totally Kido there's no
suffering Anita absolutely no care and
it's an immune system builder absolutely
you have to check this out I think you
should hurry up watch the recipe and
make it yourself it's just so easy to be
keto
what is it simple it's super simple we
hope you enjoy making it as much as we
are enjoying eating